I love that you guys have to stay here
so I really don't have to be that funny
it's like you could not leave the room
and I did enjoy me meeting John and in
the back before we start I just have to
say he asked me what my husband did and
somehow the conversation came up that he
used to be a rapper and I made mistake I
said oh yeah and he was most known for
two songs shake it like a white girl and
college girls are easy and I was like
that probably wasn't the right thing to
say to the Dean of a school I was like
oh never mind never mind anyway okay so
I'm happy to be here so Sarah thanks for
being here yeah thanks for having
clearly we're excited to have you I'm
particularly excited to have you here I
never thought I'd be saying this to a
view from the top speaker but if it
weren't for you I don't think I would
have been able to zip up these pants
today so I'm so honored thank you you
famously started Spanx with $5,000 in
your bank account what was the hardest
part about getting Spanx off the ground
the hardest part about getting these
things off the ground was definitely in
the very beginning when you have when
you first have an idea as an inventor
and you thought of something that
doesn't exist and you want to bring it
into the world there were two things
that were happening one was my own
self-doubt was a really hard part of the
journey and and then the beginning of
all the manufacturers that I was having
to cold call and talk to to try to get
my product made we're all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so I heard the word know
for two straight years trying to get it
made which then increases the self-doubt
that can happen and one of the
interesting things about being an
inventor is you don't go to school for
it there isn't an inventor class
you can't major in inventing and so it's
really a belief system in yourself and
the willingness to look stupid or to
have people laugh at you or to fail at
something that you believe in your your
own gut check on that and so it takes a
lot of confidence so that was that was
the hardest part of my journey there was
a lot of starting and stopping and like
am I crazy and everyone's saying no and
but I you know I kept picking myself
back up to pursue it what was it was it
confidence that kept you going in the
early days what was it that kept you
coming back well my life was pretty much
sucked so that always helps
I was selling fax machines door-to-door
for seven years and as mentioned you
know I this wasn't mentioned but I had
wanted to be a lawyer my father was a
trial attorney and I used to actually
ask to get out of school growing up to
watch him and closing arguments and I
debated all through high school I
debated in college and I'm basically a
really bad test taker and so I bombed
the LSAT and I bombed it not once but
twice and so it set my life on on a
different course for you know I always
say things like that happen and then you
end up you know like those those moments
in your life where you think I can't
believe this is happening to me is often
times life's way of nudging you and just
letting you know you're off course well
thank goodness you persisted because
today we have Spanx and today's Spanx
has moved far beyond the world of
undergarments at different points in the
company's history
you've both taken on and walked away
from the role of CEO what has driven
those shifts well in the early days I
mean as an entrepreneur you're every
department so I was the before and after
but model literally I took a picture of
my own but took it to Kinkos got it
laminated with and without Spanx on
stood in the stores and I'm like hey
look what this can do for you I was I
was like the packer and shipper I was
the head of sales I was everything and
you learned very quickly what you're
good at and what you're not good at and
what you enjoy and what you don't enjoy
and there's usually a correlation
between the two and so I often say as
soon as you can
for to hire your weaknesses and a few
years into Spanx
it was abundantly clear that the lane
that I needed to stay and was inventing
selling promoting Spanx actually he's
never advertised Spanx is 18 years old
and the first time we've ever even
sampled an ad was to in 16 and so I was
sort of the the advertisement and and me
being out in the field talking about the
product and sharing the story of the why
why we're making this why it's better
was a big part of the formula and I
needed someone to be in the company
day-to-day running the daily operations
so I hired a CEO she was a co CEO with
me for a while and then she became the
full-time CEO and she was that for 12
years and then I stepped back in as CEO
about two years ago it's been two years
and a lot of that has to do with timing
I have four children under the age of
eight and so I was growing and building
my family and it just organically feels
like the right time for me to do that
inside of the company and so I still AM
able to stay in my lane it's just
slightly structured differently where I
have a very strong management team
around me running the day-to-day
operations you still hold 100% ownership
over spanks and you made a conscious
decision to never take money from
outside investors why I never needed to
I mean I just I never needed to so I
don't know if it was a super conscious
decision along the way more than just I
I didn't really have the need I thanks
was profitable from the first month that
I was in business and I I'm in of the
belief system for me in my journey to
start small think big and scale fast and
a lot of people want to start big and
think big and oftentimes get ahead of
themselves and and that can end wildly
successfully but it can also cause a lot
of problems and you dilute yourself down
a lot and you know then you have a lot
of other people you're answering to so
that just was the journey that I took
you know I mean is I started it with
five grand I've never had any outside
funding
and whatever money I made from selling
Spanx
I just put back into the business I love
that start small think big do you want
to run Spanx forever you know I I'm so I
operate off gut and intuition and I
think when the time is right I'll know
it if you know when I first started
Spanx I've never taken a business class
I've never worked in fashion or retail
when I started Spanx and about six
months after I started it all these
people kept coming up to me at business
events or cocktail parties or wherever
and said Sara what's your exit strategy
I was like what are you talking about
like I didn't even know what that meant
and so eventually I started telling
people my exit strategy is I want to
exit a room and look good that's my exit
strategy so the best exit strategy you
mentioned that you're an inventor first
many aspiring entrepreneurs even in this
room struggle to find their initial idea
how do you constantly find ways to
invent new products and where does your
inspiration come from you know I I mean
I think of a lot of ideas at traffic
lights I think of them all the time in
different places and I think it's part
of just being hyper observant I I like
to find white space I pay attention to
what are things that haven't evolved and
why you know like there's certain things
in our society that updates itself and
changes and and you know constantly and
then there's certain things that it's
not and so I'll ask myself questions all
day every day it's just the way my brain
works like I could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that
when was the table first created is that
the actual best design for a table or
could there be something different and
you know what Spanx went into men's and
that was randomly how that happened was
because I got curious that the man's
undershirt was created in 1918 and no
one had paid any attention to it since
it was literally the same thing and so I
just you know talked to my brother and
my husband about it and their
undershirts that the neck stretched out
or they were boxy and bulky under clue
and I thought I'm just gonna add a
little bit of lycra to the cotton
undershirt for men and so the neck won't
stretch out I'm gonna taper it in at the
waist so ideas come to me like that like
our latest invention is arm tights and
ladies you want to stand anyone wearing
an arm tight they just showed me these I
was very excited stand up okay here we
go
so like Jennifer and Naomi have them and
I feel like there was somebody oh yeah
[Music]
jacket on okay that's why okay anyway so
the invention the idea for arm tights is
literally just I mean there's so much
that comes from being a frustrated
consumer so I'm a woman I'm looking at
my closet most of my favorite things are
sleeveless like a sleeveless shirt a
sleeveless dress and I'm like you know
what I want to wear that differently and
I also want to wear it year-round so I
just want something that goes underneath
on my arms super simple and lots of
different colors I don't want to always
have to put a cardigan or a jacket or
something over it come fall or winter
when you're transitioning in spring or
even inside of office buildings I'm cold
a lot and I don't want the integrity of
my shirt or my dress to be covered up so
that's how arm tights it's a little crop
top made on a hosiery types machine
which had never been done before and you
put it on over your head it stops just
below your bra and the reason that is
for that is less bulk under your clothes
it's super breathable easy to wear and
then it's just literally like with one
$30 item your whole closet exponentially
grows with looks and how you want to
layer it and wear it I love it but yeah
ideas really up clearly I love I have my
assistant who's my right hand Lisa she's
been my right hand for 16 years can
attest to this but I have 99 pages I
don't know why it's 99 but she told me
the other day it's 99 pages single
spaced typed of ideas
one more idea so ie I think of ideas
constantly on airplanes in car you know
talking to somebody and I email it to
myself and then I just keep them and
logged them Oh
take note you've said that you
deliberately approached banks with a
degree of feminism you had rarely seen
in business can you elaborate on that
for us well I don't know about that I
just I I approached it with a very
feminine leadership style and so I think
that there's there's you know
traditional business has been very
masculine and it's been a very masculine
model and so I approach it I mean and
when I say that I when I first started
Spanx I was maybe three months in and I
was at a cocktail party and I these
three guys came up to me and they said
Sara so we heard you invented something
and I said yes I did and they said great
and one guy you know pat me on the
shoulder and he said I hope you're ready
to go to war and he said business is war
and I just remember looking at him and
thinking why and I went home that night
and and sat in my apartment and I sat on
the floor and I was thinking about all
that was happening and you know this
risk I was taking and potentially
leaving my debt job and the secure
income and and just thinking I don't
want to go to war and this voice inside
of my head just said do it different
like take a totally different approach
and so I have approached Spanx with very
feminine principles and there's there's
the feminine and the masculine in all of
us and it's all super important but you
know using vulnerability really
operating off of intuition if the data
is trumping my intuition I go with my
intuition almost every time so you know
that's not typical in in a corporate
environment so those kinds of things
that I've done like being vulnerable
with the business I am I felt as a
consumer I I just felt like companies
aren't really talking to me the way that
I want them to talk to me I know I'm not
listening to them I don't believe them I
don't necessarily trust them and so when
I started Spanx I instead of
talking you know at my customer I wanted
to talk to them and I made myself
vulnerable so I like I joked and said I
used my own but in the before and after
picture but I had felt like companies
were operating in this like we need to
be perfect and you need to see us as the
authority and you need me and that's how
I'm gonna sell you product and I was
like hey like I'm one of you like here's
here's what's happening here's what it
does for me
this is why it works and it was just a
very different approach and I felt like
consumers became really connected and
really loyal and probably part of the
reason why Spanx as a brand didn't need
to advertise for six I mean we haven't
spent any money on advertising in 16
years because of a lot of it's word of
mouth from women sharing with other
women yeah if that flashing example in
the green room we had earlier was any
example of what that virality looks like
for you then I can only imagine can you
tell us about a meaningful experience
here to get John to flash but he wasn't
wearing any Spanx moving on from that
can you tell us about a meaningful
experience you've had mentoring young
women since founding Spanx I mean sure I
a lot of different women come to mind
you know I I look for women that I can
support what they're doing in the
education and and in their businesses
and entrepreneurship but there's a group
of 10 women that I started supporting
and mentoring in Atlanta I wanted to
kind of do something really close to
home who are all doing social impact
type businesses for the community of
Atlanta and that's been really rewarding
and wonderful to watch and all of them
now have crossed the million dollar mark
and
I do a lot of work with Grameen America
helping female entrepreneurs living
below the poverty line here in the
United States one woman comes to mind
Brittney Underwood who started a Cola
jewelry and I mentored her a little bit
as well in addition to you know helping
to support her and mentioned that she
should try to sell her product at Neiman
Marcus and as a result you know Accola
jewelry is that all the Neiman's and
she's doing a fabulous job giving women
particularly in Dallas homeless women
employment and it start her company
started in Uganda but you know the
reality is people been asking me for 18
years multiple times a day for 10
minutes of my time to mentor them or to
help them and and so I'm working on a
digital format for that and it's in beta
right now and it's just a way to answer
how did I do this and the real answer of
how I did this is Spanx started way
before I cut the feet out of my
pantyhose
that's the soundbite in the press that
everybody's talked about for almost 20
years but it actually started
fundamentally on when I was 16 I worked
on mind set for myself and I'm such a
believer in mind set is almost
everything and it just happened to be a
set of circumstances I was riding my
bike with one of my best friends at 16
and she was run over by a car and killed
in front of me and then a few months
later my dad left home and my parents
separated and ultimately got divorced
and when my dad moved out he came into
my bedroom and he handed me a cassette
tape series called how to be a No Limit
person by Wayne Dyer and he said sweetie
I wish I discovered this when I was your
age instead of the age of 40 and then he
moved out and so I started listening to
this how to be a No Limit person which
was talking about visualization law of
attraction not caring about what other
people think about you the fear you know
not being consumed by the fear of
failure and it's just the clouds parted
for me and I thought you know I've spent
a lot of time being taught what to think
but no one's really teaching me how to
think and it's
tene I was so incredibly important so in
this digital platform it's kind of
passing on a lot of these insights that
deal with mindset that I think is the
real reason that Spanx exists so you
have this incredible mindset at the age
of 16 and you're kind of almost paying
it forward by empowering women around
you what role do you hope the Sara
Blakely foundation will play in the
empowerment of women well I mean my
ultimate goal is that the male and
female energy on the planet becomes
balanced so I feel like all right well
good that one person who agrees with me
yeah so anyway the male and female
energy on the planet more balanced and
the reason why I say energy I mentioned
earlier is that we all have the male and
the female energy inside of us and I
feel like the feminine has been pretty
squashed for a long time on our planet
and it's not serving the greater whole
so what can I do in my short lifetime to
elevate the feminine and and that's what
the foundation is focused on in how can
I help the elevating and supporting that
and I take my opportunity as a woman in
this country so seriously and I think
part of the reason that I do is because
I got to watch my mom and my
grandmothers and their lack of options
and that was really hard and so you know
we've been on the planet for thousands
of years or millions of years depending
on who you ask and what you think but
the bottom line is my mom is only 22
years older than me and my mom had about
three or four options only afforded to
her because she was a woman so in the
grand scheme of life and how long we've
been on earth I'm like I made it by 22
years like what you're kidding me so I
feel like a lot of my courage and you
know I'm scared of a lot of things I
mean I'm afraid to fly I'm afraid of
heights like I've got all kinds of
things but I feel like where I get my
courage is that Retta knowing and
thinking about I'm a woman born in the
right place at the right time I don't
want to squander that
and I want to make the most of that
you're definitely a family woman we see
that a lot your family's featured on
your Instagram a lot how have your how
is your relationship with your mother
and grandmother influenced you well I
think they influenced me I mean I love
my mom and my grandmothers so much there
my mom is the most supportive person
ever but they influenced me more by what
they didn't do than what they did so you
know my mom's an artist she's very sweet
she's very soft-spoken she has low
confidence but is a lovely and probably
the sweetest person I've ever known in
my life and and she was wonderful mother
so I have four children under the age of
eight I have an eight-year-old boy twin
boys that are three and a two year old
daughter so this is vacation for me I'm
so happy to be here I woke up in my
hotel room and I'm like oh we're happy
to have you mentioned that you have so
many fears including the fear of heights
but you're known as a leader who does
not shy away from her fears
so yes you are terrified of heights but
you've climbed on top of a hot air
balloon and to be clear this is on top
not in the basket to drink tea with Sir
Richard Branson what fuels your drive to
face your fears head-on as a leader
honestly the opportunity to be a woman
like I feel like when you when you're
doing something in life or you're living
your life for something beyond just
yourself you'll get courage you didn't
know you had and so I really feel like
when I do things I'm like I'm doing this
for women doing this for women you know
and it just helps me but that was a
particularly in insane moment in my life
I did a reality show with Sir Richard
Branson many many years ago and it was
his take on The Apprentice and instead
of the business challenges all taking
place in one city like New York they
took place around the world and instead
of and this was the fine print I didn't
totally read instead of if you
got you lost your business challenge
instead of getting in the boardroom and
him firing you you had to do a world
record-breaking death-defying stunt with
Richard which I should have known
because there was a 27 page contract
that came over from Fox that I was
supposed to sign and I emailed it to my
dad who I mentioned is a litigator and
the contract basically was like we can
submerge you underwater we can put you
in political unrest we can fight you on
fire I mean it was crazy and I emailed
it to my dad and I said dad can you help
me kind of tweak this and give me some
advice and he all he wrote back was no
sane person would sign this love dad so
I signed it of course and I spent two
months with Richard Branson and I just
trusted my intuition that he wasn't
gonna portray me in a way you know on
with Fox because literally my lawyer was
on his hand he's like don't do this
you're four years into Spanx why would
you ever put you know but well the first
day of filming I at 3:00 in the morning
they woke us all up and they said you
know we're gonna go out into the field
by Richard Branson's home and in Oxford
England and they handed me a helmet and
I was like why do I need a helmet an
entrepreneur they're like here's your
helmet and I got in a hot air balloon
and two hot air balloons went up into
the air over the English countryside
first thing in the morning and it was at
about 9,000 10,000 feet and there was a
balance beam connecting the two hot-air
balloons and you were asked to walk
across the balance beam and I was on one
of only two people couldn't do it
where'd they people come from and so
anyway I was like I can't you know and
then when they disconnected the two
hot-air balloons and Richard turned to
me and he said Sara you know because you
and Tim couldn't get across the balance
beam I had to do something twice as hard
and I had to climb on a dangling rope
ladder the whole circumference of the
hot-air balloon at 10,000 feet in the
air going across the English countryside
and have meet him on top of the balloon
40
so sounds fun it took me 48 minutes to
climb the balloon it was insanely hard
and yeah so so my friend I don't know
somebody friend Leslie gave this to me
last night over dinner and it's so cool
it's a hot air balloon with someone
dangling off of it I'm like thank you
very much it will remind me of the the
courage it took me or the insanity to
that to do that since that show Richard
Branson has become sort of a mentor to
you what does that relationship and that
mentorship mean to you and what does
mentorship mean to you more generally as
well well he actually B's a friend he's
a great friend and you know what I like
about Richard is he has an incredible
bias for action he is someone who just
goes and you just marvel at it he
requires very little sleep he's always
got a notebook with them and he's always
writing ideas in it
he's a great delegator he doesn't ask
anybody to do anything he won't do
himself and he's funny I mean he won't
talk about a prankster
he's funny like he likes to prank people
so you just have to always be prepared
when you're around him that something's
gonna jump out oh yeah we have your
helmet exactly
so speaking of humor as you know here at
the GSB we have a class about humor in
business which I love respect is all
great I think it's so important yeah
really important so tell me why is that
important I know that as part of the
spanks training boot camp one of the
mandatory learning modules is comedy
that every employee has to go through so
why is that important yeah well I just
found out in the greenroom that I'm one
of only two CEOs that you guys are aware
of that also done stand-up comedy and
the other one is who started Twitter
right yep so I guess that would make me
the only female CEO that ever done
stand-up comedy ball I the part of also
wanting to stay very connected to the
feminine principles and the feminine
style of leadership starting Spanx I
also felt like I want it I didn't
understand why why everybody was so
serious
so I thought you know what I don't
subscribe to the fact that you have to
act serious to be taken seriously and I
like to laugh at myself I you know I
looked when I worked in corporate
America for a long time and everybody
was super uptight and super serious
there was no humor and there was no
levity and then everybody at like 5:00
o'clock became ragingly hilarious like
what's going on like you know and so the
alcohol probably helped you know but but
anyway I I wanted to to use humor and I
loved to do that in the workplace
and yes we have a boot camp at Spanx a
training boot camp when you come on
board and one of the modules is doing
stand-up comedy and I've used the
comedic stuff that I did in my marketing
I mean I wrote don't worry we've got
your butt covered right on my package
when I first started in 2000 which was
not very common to do especially taking
it to the neiman-marcus to sell it
I named my company Spanx which was you
know made people laugh and believe it or
not it was very shocking at the time
that I named the company Spanx that
actually had people hang up on me often
I would call them and say hi I'm Sara
from Spanx and then they'd hang up and
I'd call back and I go I'm serious I'm a
real company and my company's called
spinning and they go oh I thought you
were prank calling me so and then you
know naming my products I broke into the
world's most boring category I mean can
we talk about shapewear who wants to
talk about shapewear and undergarments
but it was I named it power panties you
know I started naming all my products
and it made people laugh and it gave so
much energy and then all of a sudden you
had Gwyneth Paltrow and Julia Roberts
flashing their Spanx on red carpets and
saying I'm wearing Spanx like all these
celebrities and I think it's because I
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that so so I used it in in every
aspect of the marketing I use humor to
turn around a situation when I'm bombing
it it might give me a second chance when
I cold called to sell fax machines
door-to-door for seven years I learned
very quickly that if I could make
somebody laugh or smile I'd get another
30 seconds before they'd slam the door
in my face there's just it's helps you
move through pain it's it's it's a
wonderful
tool what impact have you seen humor
have on your bank's employees well
they're not as afraid to fail which is a
really critical lesson and I think
companies if you can create a culture
where they're not terrified to fail or
make a mistake then you're gonna you're
gonna be a highly productive and more
innovative culture so having people feel
free to laugh at themselves and watching
me as their leader laugh at myself I
have oops meetings at spanks where we
get up and I tell them what I messed up
at or a mistake that I made and I
usually tell a funny story about it and
I encourage everybody else in the
company to stand up and say that and
then share and make it a funny story and
so I think that that helps you have any
stand-up comedian role models I I don't
you know I like Tina Fey a lot I think
she's fabulous and super funny and I
didn't grow up watching comedy or
stand-up comedians I told you how to
crush on Gene Wilder had a crush on Gene
Wilder when I was little and I tried to
join the gene Wilder fan club wasn't one
all my friends were like had crushes on
Andy Gibb and all these other fan clubs
and I looked up the Jan my mom tried to
find the Gene Wilder fan club and
apparently I was the only one trying to
join that but I think he's so fabulous
and funny and and very sexy and I my
husband actually looks a lot like gene
mother like crazy curly hair going in
every direction what lessons did you
take away from your time as a stand-up
comedian ah what lessons do I take I
mean well one thing that I learned that
was random this isn't really a takeaway
but like the green room I'm just like
why is it called the green room it's not
green the green room is never green and
then after about six months of doing
stand-up comedy everyone in the room was
either throwing up or about to throw up
and I'm like oh that's why it's called
the green room like we're all just
sitting there green but I mean I learned
because I wrote all my own comedy so I
had notebooks and notebooks full of
comedy so I learned the importance of
one word I learned the importance of a
comma I learned the importance of timing
I mean you could tell a joke
and the next night tell a joke and
change one word in it and it's like a
completely different reaction it's flat
so there's so much importance in in the
delivery and in how you write comedy I
let's see I mean I learned so much I
learned that I needed to go invent
something cuz I actually wasn't that
funny
to create a full-time career out of it
but as an entrepreneur I've seen you
kind of pull threads of comedy as you
mentioned you've said that you try to go
out of your way to embarrass yourself on
a regular basis why is that well I'm I'm
curious about the things that hold power
over us and one of the big fears is fear
of embarrassment we all have that we
have fear of failure so I'm always
working on these things that I feel like
might hold me back and so if I embarrass
myself then it loses its power over me
and especially if embarrassing myself at
times becomes the goal then it feels
like I don't know it's like I'm playing
my I'm like playing my own head games
with myself on that but like one example
of embarrassing myself is you know I
joined Instagram and I joined F feel
like I might be the last one on the
planet to have joined it was about a
year ago and my team is like join
Instagram you got to do it you got to
put yourself out there and I was nervous
I wasn't sure like I don't know and the
day that I joined I happened to be
flying to New York on business and I was
at the Atlanta Airport and so I was like
I'm gonna go around the airport and
personally asked people to follow me and
it was so embarrassing and I was
mortified and I was embarrassing myself
and I posted the whole video it's like
my first post on Instagram is me cuz I'm
like how does this work how do you get
followers so I was around you know
Jackson Hartfield Airport and I even
like stood up in the video I'm filming
myself and I make an announcement at my
gate I'm like excuse me I'm Sara Blakely
and I just joined Instagram today will
you follow me and literally I go like
that's not one person looks about really
I was like thank you thank you I was
gonna ask if it worked but not many more
followers so you've given us many
examples of how you've been able to push
yourself to face your fears what fears
have you not figured out how to face yet
you
I mean I can't really think of one I
work hard at them and sometimes my fear
of heights and flying is winning and
sometimes I'm winning it at it you know
I have fear of public speaking sometimes
I'm winning sometimes I'm not at that
you know there's just a lot of different
things but there's nothing that I I feel
like I'm not trying and working
so Sarah you talked about your Instagram
account where you share literally
unfiltered moments as a mom as a wife as
a friend and as a leader what keeps you
so unbelievably grounded amid all your
resounding success
I feel like success just makes you more
of who you already were
I feel like money and success just does
that so it's like it holds a magnifying
glass up to who you are people you know
people always ask you that and I'm like
I don't know who else to be I mean I am
Who I am so the money the success and so
I like to say if you were a jerk before
you got really successful and a lot of
money you become a bigger jerk easily
and if you were insecure you'll become
more insecure if you were nice you
become nicer if you were generous you
become more generous it's literally just
a magnifying glass but yeah I am you
know people ask me I don't know any
other way to be just going through it
figuring it out along the way
awesome well I know there's a couple of
people in the audience who have
questions for you so I'm gonna hand it
over for a minute great I'm so if you
have if you have a question please raise
your hand and we'll get a mic to you
hi thank you so much for being here my
name is Beth and I'm a second year and
about to have to leave this place uh the
question that I've been wondering about
and that you've spoken about a little
bit is I mean your Instagram is just
awesome like there there are not other
CEOs who I want to spend time like
seeing what they're up to in their daily
life and I'm wondering you know what you
think other people who are running
companies and and and businesses can
learn from how you think about
communication through social media well
you know I I I haven't thought that much
about what other people are and aren't
doing I I love the idea of leaders and
CEOs showing vulnerabilities and showing
the ups and downs and you know I just I
just don't really subscribe in the
feeling that I need to put on any kind
of a facade to be taken seriously as a
leader and so it's like this is my life
this is Who I am
I'm a mom of four some days I'm working
it out some days I'm not and and I think
that that that's important I also I sort
of have my own filter for Instagram I
don't it's not planned out I do it 100%
myself and I'm having fun with it and if
I wake up one day and it's not fun
anymore then I'll figure out a plan B
but so it everything kind of happens
organically and in the moment for for my
Instagram and I tend to think before I
do it or if it's happening is this gonna
inspire someone or make them feel better
you know I'm kind of interested in
making other people feel like they're
not in it alone or it's not it's not the
projection of a perfect life
how much for being here we're so excited
to have you I'm Brittany I'm an MBA too
as well about to graduate and so as dean
Levin mentioned you're famous and very
much admired for your hustle I think the
story of paying your friends to go buy
our product from the shelves in human
Marcus is one that many of us have heard
and I'm just curious kind of what Hustle
means to you whether you think it can be
learned and also whether it's possible
to take hustle too far hey that's a good
question that's a few questions I'm
gonna try to hit them all I've got
momy memory so I'm gonna start with the
first one which was what do I think of
Hustle I feel like Hustle is the
willingness to work really really hard
and then also your willingness to get
the job done like kind of navigating and
doing what it takes and and so I yeah
I've there's so much about my journey
where I was like I am NOT gonna let the
outcome or my success be contingent on
other people as much as I can control it
help it navigate it I'm going to so so
yeah in the beginning especially still
now I mean obviously I'm hustling I'm
like at this where I am now and I'm
running around the airport asking people
to follow me on Instagram you know I
just feel like it's innate in me also to
a degree but the in the beginning it's
like there's a few examples that come to
mind you mentioned that I paid my I
called my friends and asked them to go
buy Spanx and I wrote to everybody
checks and sent them a check because I
needed to drive momentum and I had no
money to advertise so I'm like this
products gonna sit on the Shelf so I
needed to get people to go in and buy it
I also when I went into the stores I
realized very quickly that my product
was in the sleepiest part of the
department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there so
then I immediately went to a Target and
I bought envelope dividing dividers that
you put on your home desk and I ran
around Neiman Marcus and put them at
every register
and I put Spanx in them and then I
walked away and Neiman's has like
impeccable visual rules and regulations
and and I did that because I had to get
my product out of the department and
because I did that women in shoes
started buying Spanx and women in
contemporary and and those decisions
made such a big difference and by the
time somebody figured out that nobody
else had approved it because I you know
everybody thought somebody else approved
it it was so successful that the head of
Neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it I mean I
have so many stories like that of just
what do I need to do
I am a second-year biophysics PhD
student my question is what advice did
you receive about getting Spinks off the
ground in the first few years good or
bad and what approach did you take to
taking this mentorship or advice into
consideration and how did you navigate
meshing that advice with what you wanted
to do based off of your intuition and
plan for your company okay so what
advice did I get in the beginning we
have compound questions what advice was
I given in the beginning of Spanx I mean
I I remember somebody saying to me as I
was delegating and growing and getting
bigger that they said Sarah if it's 80%
as good as you could do it yourself let
it go and be very happy and that was so
freeing for me because I think I was
trying I was always critiquing in my
mind like I couldn't you know that
wasn't a hundred percent exactly the way
and I was just like that became a really
important lesson for me in in growing
the business and letting go more no I I
it's so funny I I didn't have I don't
have a mentor and I didn't have I never
took a business class and Wayne Dyer the
gentleman I mentioned he's no longer
living he died almost two years ago I
think the inspirational motivational
speaker was someone that I really kind
of taught me without ever knowing him
then I'm sorry you had like two or three
more questions in there did I answer
them or okay cool
we'll take maybe one last question from
the audience before hi I'm mark I'm an
MBA one so I'm not graduating for a
little bit hi mark hey a quick question
you talked a lot about intuition versus
data and decision making and also
failing I'm curious if there's a
situation where the numbers would have
led you one way your intuition led you
another and it was a failure in kind of
what you learned from it
if an example of intuition not working
or we'll see I guess example where your
intuition may be led was a mistake I
cannot give one example I can't I can
give examples on the other end of not
listening to my intuition and it being a
mistake but there's been so much along
the way where I and it requires you
being quiet and and being receptive and
and listening to whatever the knowing is
inside of you it requires that I'd love
to take the final question if that's
okay Sara you've said the harder you
work the more the universe will believe
how serious you are about your goals and
dreams and will then show up to help how
much of your success do you attribute to
your hard work versus luck handed over
by the universe I think they're so
related I really feel like they're one
in the same and you know I mentioned
when I first started Spanx I was selling
fax machines sorted or I had a
particularly bad day I literally did get
escorted out of buildings almost all day
every day and people ripped up my
business card in my face often and one
day I just pulled off the side of the
road and I was like this is not my life
I'm in the wrong movie called the
director called the producer like cut
this is not happening and I went home to
my apartment and I wrote my strengths I
was like what am I good at and pretty
much the only thing in the good column
was sales and so I started asking myself
well what is it what is it about sales
that I'm good at and I realized I like
giving somebody something or selling
them something that could help them or
change their life or make them feel good
so I actually wrote in my journal that
night I'm going to invent a product that
I can sell to millions of people that
will make them feel good and then I
specifically asked the universe for the
idea and I said out loud in my apartment
universe give me the idea and two years
later I cut the feet out of my pantyhose
to go to a party I couldn't figure out
what to wear under white pants and I did
it only one time because I was so
and receptive to what the universe was
going to provide for me and it took two
years and I was always looking but it
showed up and I was gonna pursue it I
wasn't sure if that was the idea or not
so I've been in partnership with the
universe I feel like the universe you
know my CFO who's you know a little bit
more analytical minded than I am she now
she now says the universe is the best
employee on the payroll because they're
free free so she's now a believer and
you know what's so funny is about like I
when I first started Spanx - I joined a
group and they put me in a forum of men
and there were only men in this
entrepreneurial it's like a YPO across
the country and they put me in my
chapter in Atlanta and I got put in with
10 guys I'm the only girl I have met
with these 10 guys every single month
for 17 years now they're like my
brothers but they will tell you when I
first started they were all taking bets
in the group of how long I'd be in
business and they're you know I would
always say things like they'd go around
the room and talk about things then I
would say wives I've asked the universe
to do this and I taking care of this and
I have visualized that I'm gonna be on a
woman and I have you know and they're
like and so and then and then like my
results kept going up and up and up and
then eventually after a couple years one
by one and I'm not kidding every single
one of them pulled me aside secretly I
was like so how do you talk to the
universe
[Applause]